and so when you look into the bitcoin
world
i think that when you look at the
optimization for security similar to
gold
store value people hold it purchasing
power has gone up
a lot year over year it's like a 200
percent year-over-year compounded annual
growth
for over a decade right and so you
measure this in kind of the us dollar
exchange price et cetera
but there's still a lot of people who
will yell and scream about it's slow
it's costly right all the things around
those transactions
that are obstacles or challenges and so
there's basically two schools of thought
and this is where we kind of get into
the bifurcation
some people just said hey this
technology is antiquated we can't use it
it doesn't make sense
uh and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna go build something new and so you
go get you know kind of all of the
various versions there
the bitcoin community says no just like
gold had paper claims and other things
built on top and layer two three four
five
we're gonna do that here and so they've
already started to build kind of this
layer two
where it's easier to transact it's
cheaper it's faster etc
and so i actually think that both of
those worlds are going to co-exist in
the future
the big question is just which one has
more importance
right so again get out of binary it's
just probabilistically
and so my personal belief is that the
security the the
store of value component as the bedrock
for a monetary system
is essential right like that is the uh
most important thing because you can
always
improve the other components but you
can't go back and fix that kind of core
piece
so if money money is a an idea that we
all
it's like an emergent idea that we
believe in you're saying that security
is one of the most fundamental catalysts
or fuels
for that idea to sort of take hold and
be
stable and sort of take over the world
the other stuff is really nice to have
but if you don't have the security
you're not going to
like it's it's not going to spread in a
viral sense in in our
human brains well and especially in
light of
the kind of the macro economy right so
like what's so fascinating about the
last 12 months
is um in investing in general the best
returns right i kind of put that in air
quotes a little bit is something that is
different
than everything else and right so being
different and wrong just means you're an
idiot
right being different and right means
that that's where kind of the outsized
returns are
and so if you look around the world at
currencies today they're all the same
they're all inflationary unlimited
supply controlled by a government
done and decisions made in a very
non-transparent process
and what we've watched is the
manipulation of all of those currencies
over the last 12 months
in direct contrast to that is this thing
bitcoin
which is outside of the system has a
finite supply
transparent and programmatic monetary
policy and so when you see those two
systems
kind of um in comparison to each other
in the united states
there's a lot of people who say the
dollar works great for me i can go to
the atm i can get out physical cash
if i want to swipe a card i could do
that my money and my bank doesn't lose
50 of its value in a day
in terms of purchasing power like the
dollar's pretty good
when you go to other countries that
might not be the case
and so i do think that there's uh kind
of a relative analysis that goes on here
if you compare bitcoin to the dollar
there's all kinds of arguments to make
that the dollar is better as a medium of
exchange today
but if i go and i tell you what about in
you know these kind of extreme
examples of venezuela zimbabwe turkey
etc
and so i think that that's kind of one
perspective to view this through
is security versus all of the innovative
components of a medium of exchange etc
you